Joe Thomas here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you Joe I'm doing great thank
you for having me on
no look Joe anything that I can do to
help your cause to buy the Panthers I'm
here for you Matt I appreciate that I
expect a lot of bidding wars in the next
few months here but I'm feeling really
confident about the group that I've put
together and I'm feeling like the
chances are pretty good that I'll be the
next owner of the Carolina Panthers do
you know what Joe I learned early on
being around top-flight athletes like
yourself top-flight individuals like
yourself is first things first you got
to believe it right deep down in your
soul that you've got it right you don't
believe in yourself who's gonna believe
in you so I really believe that this is
going to happen I've got a great plan
laid out in my Twitter feed and I think
it's only a matter of time well you
wanted a million retweets and right now
unfortunately you know you're about nine
hundred thousand-plus shy of that I
don't know if you've been keeping track
of your retweets well you know I think
the retweets are merely just a number
I'm really just focused on the plan at
this point and you know I've got my
people working behind the scenes with
all the necessary people and but like I
said you know the retweets are gonna get
there but right now my sole focus is on
the plan and the execution of that plan
well maybe Joe Thomas people just don't
understand your agenda what you'd bring
to the equation for instance when did he
put out his video on Instagram he talked
about how he was going to have the the
best halftime shows which is a very
difficult thing for you to compete with
correct well if people want to see Diddy
at halftime I can clearly just pay him
enough money and he'll perform it happen
that really should not be okay any
reason that people would prefer Diddy
over me all right and then let's get
your agenda as you tweet it out Joe
Thomas you said that you would if you
get the Panthers not have a punter or a
kicker cuz you're going for it on fourth
down every time let's take that part
first what why are you such a fourth
down junkie Joe well I realized that the
NFL isn't entertained
business and nobody hates the kicking
and punting plays more than an offensive
lineman so I think we need to give the
fans what they want we need to go for it
we need to be risk takers and I think
when you waste roster spots on kickers
and punters those are roster spots that
could be taken by more left tackles so I
don't see why you'd want to waste it on
kickers and punters you know you need to
save that money for your left tackle you
need to save those roster spot for those
up-and-coming left tackles mmm you know
you saw McAfee responds right because
when you talk that way about kickers
you're gonna hear it from Pat McAfee Joe
Thomas you're gonna hear you know him
and his army have been trolling me
incessantly on Twitter since I put that
out there so I'm working on a way to
smooth things over maybe I give him a
front office role to kind of fly them
down there maybe he could be your vice
owner your VP right yes everybody needs
a good man behind the scenes working
hard maybe Pat could be that guy well he
could take care of your halftime show
that's for damn sure he could do his
podcast he's the entertainer
he's the entertainer we could just put
him out there with a microphone and have
him tell jokes for 10 minutes during
halftime but I got to tell you Joe I
mean certainly in these parts as you
know I'm a punter people to movement guy
I've been I've been at the forefront of
this I have an issue here I mean punters
are weapons Joe punters are weapons you
know maybe we need to talk about that a
little bit further I'm not sure I
totally agree with you but there are
certainly people but I'm not sure
they're football players Thomas well why
because they watch they watch soap
operas during practice is that what
you're saying I have always been jealous
of the punter since I was in college and
we were outside sweating it out to the
oldies at practice and those punters
were inside in the air-conditioning
watching daytime soaps while we practice
so there's obvious a little bitter
little jealousy going on that's been
deep inside of me for a lot of years
okay and then another part of your of
your pitch if you will to buy the
Carolina Panthers Joe Thomas is you want
to rename the team to the Carolina
mission barbecues what's that all about
Joe
well as everybody knows mission barbecue
is the best barbecue restaurant in the
world and I think it only makes sense
that with new ownership the Panthers
need to take a new direction and we need
to rename the team and we need to come
up with a new logo so fans understand
this is a new exciting Carolina football
franchise so so what would the logo be
73 you can see the beautiful logo that
I've pre-selected for the fans so they
get just a little taste of the
excitement in the entertainment around
the Carolina mission barbecue well it's
it looks like your face Joe but I don't
know what would you call them what would
you call that look of the the selfie
that you put up there for the team logo
yeah that's sort of my own version of
blue steel I don't know it looks like
you're you're you're pulling something
I'll be honest okay so when it all comes
down to it Joe I mean it comes down to a
3/4 vote from folks like Jimmy Haslam
he's one of 32 have you have you gone to
the owner of the Cleveland Browns the
man who signs your paychecks and told
him about your plan to to buy the
Carolina Panthers when it's put for sale
Joe yes I've been working the back
channels I've been talking to a lot of
the influential owners in the NFL but
most importantly what I did is I told
them look guys I know how much you guys
like Roger Goodell and how much you wish
you could have paid him more my my first
order of business in the owners meeting
is to give poor Roger a raise because
he's just not well compensated enough
for all that he has to put up with as
the face of the NFL you're a giver Joe
what can I tell you man your giver your
dinner would you put me on the
competition committee so I could take
care of the catch rule and this insane
rule about fumbling through the end zone
and out of the end zone goes back to the
defense can you put me on the
competition committee for that Joe
absolutely I think that's one of the
first orders of business at the
competition committee level I think the
obviously the fumbling into the end zone
is just ridiculous whoever made that up
needs to be deported immediately because
that makes zero sense well then the
catch will obviously need revisiting so
if you believe the same things that I do
which it seems like you do you
definitely can be on my competition
treasure well I'm with you I'm with you
on everything you put out there Joe
Thomas except the punter and kicker I
don't know if I could be part of your
organization if that's the case but you
tell me reasonable Minds can disagree
but I think the important thing is to
focus on the things that we agree on
okay before I let you go how is your arm
how is it I'm doing good I actually just
started doing some rehab they put pink
dumbbells in my hand this week and I was
able to do some tricep extension feeling
like a real man how many how much is the
pink dumbbells weigh somewhere between a
half and one pound dude just don't don't
don't over exert yourself okay
sort of like Aaron Rodgers have to take
it on Carolina with 13 screws in his
clavicle very very similar and and how
does Wisconsin get get a bowl game as
Miami Hurricane home game Joe how the
hell did that happen what happened there
well interesting but I actually believe
that there's gonna be more Wisconsin
fans than there will Miami fans there
because Wisconsin fans always travel
really well they always take it as like
sort of their New Year Christmas
vacation to go down somewhere warm and
watch the Badgers for the bowl game so
I'm not just discouraged at all I think
that Wisconsin is gonna travel well and
they're gonna win that game you do
realize it's in Miami's home stadium
right you do realize that I'll be happy
to have you on the first podcast in NFL
history with Joe Thomas and you can eat
those words when you see that Stadium a
sea of red on that bowl game Joe this is
you know what this is in my business
it's a hot take that's a hot tape job I
mean that's a hot take I mean I feel
like I should be split screen with you
with a topic
at the bottom you know having an
argument about this sort of thing yes
you know I'm not a big arguing guy but I
believe strongly that Wisconsin fans
will represent well out represent Miami
fans even though it is a home game and I
still feel like they're gonna beat them
pretty handily - okay Joe look a good
luck on your campaign to purchase a team
that might go for two plus billion
dollars good luck on that and let me
help you in any way shape or form okay
rich I really appreciate you having me
on your show and allowing me to
disseminate my platform and my strategy
for buying the Carolina mission barbecue
just to let you know on the television
side of things Joe we have finished this
segment with the new logo of your face
that is you just that's one word to
describe it that's why you got it at Joe
Thomas 73 on Twitter to check it all out
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience